uh yes welcome Marina once again
congratulations well I think that you
had winning chances yesterday as well so
what a start two and a half out of three
uh well I wouldn't call you an underdog
of course but I think that all the U.S
funds are chancing out there so yeah
hopefully I'm making my fans happy
so let's have a look at the game uh can
you share a little bit uh well some
secrets of your preparation why did you
start with this line yeah well it's
funny I mean I think her triangle slav
was
um a very logical idea for her
um but the thing is that I mean it
wasn't necessarily the most obvious
thing that she could do right it was
just kind of like a logical idea the
thing is though that I thought thought
about that too right because it's so
logical that you know I thought you know
she might uh do that you know avoiding
the exchange law for example
um and yeah I went for the Marshall game
but this is something I've kind of had a
liking for for a very long time you know
like you know back when I was like a
teenager you know 20 years ago and I was
studying these lines I mean I kind of
went through all the gambas the Marshall
Gambit the Geller Gambit you know like
the anti-mozcow variation of the
vatvinic
um
so basically I mean I kind of feel like
when black doesn't control the E4 Square
it kind of makes sense to try to play in
the maximally aggressive way so what did
you expect what was the end of your
preparation was this somewhere here
basically
um Queen A3 Knight C5 Bishop D4 like I
knew this idea because it's actually far
from an obvious idea like the idea to go
Bishop D4 just trade on C5 and claim
some sort of an edge in the end game
because of your better Pawn structure is
certainly you know you know it's not the
most obvious thing unless the computer
shows you and also maybe a very
unpleasant choice for your opponent
because you deprived her for any like
she didn't have Dynamic play at all yeah
no it's true I mean Nana definitely
thrives in more like aggressive
positions and so like
I mean I wasn't sure how much there was
in this end game
um I feel like for me the big decision
was trading off all the Rooks right like
I don't know I it took me a while to
come up with this I don't know how good
it is but I kind of felt like it worked
out quite well
um yeah because after Bishop State I was
like okay what do I really have here
right um she's gonna go Knight D4 Pawnee
five and so I went for this trade of
everything which is definitely not like
meant to be a draw offer I mean I
expected to be pushing in this position
in a way it like removes even more of
the dynamic possibilities for black so
now you're like completely in a two
result game I mean you know white can't
really mess this up unless you know they
they just fall asleep or leave the board
you know
um but I thought like it's it's
unpleasant to play against the outside
Pawn majority I would never want to be
black and like in this position you know
it's a friend effect because they said
that you shouldn't trade all the Rooks
and you have to keep one yeah I don't
know it's like I just think yeah it was
not an obvious decision but I felt like
you know because if you're going to be
pushing your queen side pawns right the
more Rooks there are it's also the
trickier it is to push those Queen side
Pawns
so that maybe yes G5 was a better move
in this position just
wait and see so were you planning on
playing before like you did on the game
yeah I mean just the general plan King
D2 before I mean the thing is like yeah
the black has to really feel the
subtleties here right like for white
again it's much easier to play I mean I
thought she played logically but then
there were a couple of things that I did
that I um I thought were interesting
like
this move G4 I mean this is yeah so in
this game I did some you know funny
things with the pawns because I wound up
putting all of them on light squares
even though I'm the one with the you
know light squared Bishops I'm kind of
like breaking the rules but I was like
oh this is very interesting because I
can fight for the E4 square right so
there were definitely some paradoxical
things going on with the pawn placements
in this game and this was one of those
decisions here I was feeling like pretty
good about my position
F5 and H3 yeah that was another one I
mean I didn't know of course taking on
F5 was tempting
um but then I decided to like not
activate that Bishop for a while I see
the engine doesn't really like my choice
but in the game I was like the you know
I was pretty happy with it
while the engine is not always right so
let's get let's have a look at the uh
the most critical moments of this game
C5 you know it was amazing that like you
know I like to me I was amazed that I
was not like winning this end game I
mean after C5 B5 you think like those
and B Pawn should be really dangerous
but then I realized okay it's actually
not so simple
yes and then actually that's that was
where I uh told our audience that there
is a way to lose the same game and I
wanted to illustrate it in a very simple
way because you can play let's say E4
I'm I'm amazed like you can like you can
allow them to take an F5 and play Bishop
G4 and like black is still holding that
like that's just not obvious at all of
course it's not obvious to human mind so
after I said what's more natural than
centralize your king yeah here you are
yeah you're take your take and then you
play A6 and it means that you always had
to watch out for these ideas so I think
that your opponent forgot you know she
simply lost concentration but also I I
didn't realize it until like I really
started thinking because again Asics is
so counter-intuitive you're putting yet
another Pawn on the light square but
like I was like oh wow she's giving me
this opportunity to come into E4 and
here okay here we were so yeah this
position I I was getting a little
disappointed because I realized that
basically I thought her holding plan was
like let's say oh we can go one more or
move King E3 let's say well yeah I don't
know she could she had these options of
going H5 but like even Bishop F7 right
and so yeah I thought she would just
kind of go back to G6 after Bishop E2
and then the point is that when every
time I go Bishop D3 she just moves her
Bishop away and I never have King E4 and
this was like the big you know
realization of this end game that I
cannot actually use the E4 square with
my king so like how do I break through
you know this was probably the way for
black to hold because we tried this
variation let's say Bishop H5 King G3
but then the King has to stay close yeah
yeah I mean that was going to be you
know a disappointing thing for me to
swallow that like my A5 and B5 pawns
were not gonna win me the game
and so tell me what did you feel right
here when you saw them yeah so I was
surprised by King D6 just because I
thought the King was good on C7 and I
thought she could just hold using her
Bishop but I didn't immediately like
know what was wrong with it right so
then eventually like this A6 idea came
to be and I was just like wow it seems
to work in all the lines like her King
just has to go back my king breaks
through and that's kind of it
so A6 is the meaning move and well the
rest is history there is a very
important King march
and H4
just they're finally improving my pawns
a little bit
uh everything how do you feel now do you
realize that you're leading the
tournament well no I'm feeling good you
know I feel good about this game I feel
like you know well I'm trying to play
aggressively you know it's funny that
all three of my games despite very
different openings
um you know kind of aggressive openings
they've all gone into the end game
pretty quickly right so that's just an
interesting thing
um but yeah no I'm feeling overall that
I'm playing decently you know so I just
want to keep that up and how important
it is for you once again to
to be a role model you know you are
playing an American soil and well a lot
of young players are looking up to you
yeah well I definitely like to make
happy the people who root for me you
know like my students my fans like my
friends my family like oh like there's a
lot of categories of people that I you
know I try to make happy with my play
thank you sir you should continue thank
you all right our congratulations Arena
very very nice as Arena Crush